and you're live chairman thank you
thank you good afternoon and welcome to
this overview and scrutiny committee
meeting on thursday
15th of april 2021. my name is
councillor vanessa bell and i'm the
chairman of this committee
before we commence the business of the
meeting can i ask all in attendance to
observe a minute silence
to mark the passing of the duke of
edinburgh thank you
[Music]
thank you everybody thank you
so members this meeting is held under
new regulations which came into effect
on the 4th of april 2020
not that new anymore in response to the
covid19 situation
please could i ask everyone present in
this meeting to ensure your camera
remains on where broadband permits i
know members are having
some issues tonight and your microphone
remains muted when not addressing the
committee
this will reduce background noises and
avoid any unintentional disturbances
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting you are giving your
consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the hands up function of the
meeting
to indicate if you wish to speak you are
reminded that
apart from indicating points of order or
that you have to leave the meeting the
chat function should not be used for
questions
or any other purpose when speaking and
referring to the agenda papers please
ensure you reference a page or paragraph
number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
when invited to speak please ensure you
turn on your microphone
now if i may ask officers taking part in
the meeting to introduce themselves
starting with mrs hughes
this is good evening members cheryl
hughes programs performance and
governance manager
thank you mrs hughes
you're getting your time and gave me
members tara bird committee services
officer thank you
thank you sarah are there any other
officers present please so
identify yourselves now no before i call
on the client to take the roll call of
committee members can i ask those
counsellors
in attendance to introduce themselves
please
hi uh nick skeens in attendance
thank you councillor schoons
sarah please can you carry out a role of
committee members to confirm who is in
attendance
thank you thank you chairman members if
you could just indicate if you're here
when i call your name please
starting with councillor bassinger
please yeah good evening i'm president
thank you councilman president
thank you councillor brian beale
you're here
president tara thank you thank you
catsamori
president tara thank you and casa morris
good evening and welcome thank you very
much
thank you chairman thank you sarah good
evening everyone
um may i have the apologies for absence
please sarah
oh yes chairman apologies from received
from councillor duik thank you chairman
thank you sarah um on to item three the
minutes of the 21st of january 2021
meeting
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on 21st of january 2021
found on pages 3 to 6 are approved as a
true and accurate record
iso move if you wish to second that
motion please unmute your microphone
and state your name now i'll second that
councillor morning
thank you councillor morley so if any
member wishes to raise any matter of
accuracy
please use the hands up function to
indicate and
i will invite you to speak
councillor morris thank you chair this
was actually a hands up
uh for the previous item i was just
wondering could the clock
come from whether or not we have anyone
from the democratic alliance group with
us tonight please
uh yes chairman the um member for the
democratic alliance on the committee
is um council juric and council boys and
neither are present i can confirm
thank you so neither neither um
representative from the democratic
alliance is
present that's right yes that's right
chairman
thank you thank you thank you sarah
thank you for raising that counselor
maurice apologies that i didn't see your
hands uh
at the appropriate time
thank you so um any other members
wishing to speak
on accuracy i don't think so
so members can we agree these by ascent
or do we need
to to vote
agreed agreed agreed thank you
excellent so that brings us on to
agenda item number four public
participation and i can advise that
we've not received any submissions from
members of the public
today item five disclosure of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting
do i have any declarations members
no okay
lovely thank you so
item six we move to item agenda item six
update on agreed scrutiny items found on
pages seven to twenty four
in a moment i will call on the officer
to present this item
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak on this item
please make this known by using the
hands up function within this meeting
i will then come to you in turn please
keep your points clear and succinct
so mrs hughes can i pass over to you
please to present the report
yep no problem um good evening members
uh the headline report provides an
update for the work
plan items uh with emerging information
uh provided as appendices so i'm going
to specifically give an update as lead
officer for transformation first
on the 21st of january the committee
agreed to initialize the work plan item
for transformation
this was defined as a review to which
the original objectives were achieved
as well as identifying any wider impacts
the transformation program was signed
off in august 2018
and in the blueprint document agreed by
council there were seven work streams
set out that had
outcomes identified the report has been
put together by conducting interviews
and gathering evidence from relevant
officers
to determine to what extent the
identified outcomes have been achieved
the information is set out in appendix 1
which is found on page 11 of your pack
any areas where there were issues with
delivery specifications or time scales
have been highlighted in the learning
points section at the start of the
appendices
there is also a specific column for
customer and cost implications
and we have used feedback from our
residents and staff as well as the wider
information to populate this column
at the time of putting the report
together the finance team who've been
busy with the medium term financial
strategy and financial year end
are additionally working on wider
reconciliation exercise for
transformation around the budgets and
anticipated savings to feed into wider
reporting
within the draft report you will see
yellow highlighting which denotes where
further information is still expected to
come forwards
members are invited to review the
information set out so far
comment on areas where they feel
information is lacking but within the
brief of the item
and they are also requested that for the
transformation item specifically
we move the final report date to the
31st of may to allow for finance
to finish their work and for that to be
included in the
final conclusions thank you
you're a mute
no i'm so sorry i was having
teeth trouble and i muted myself while i
uh sorted that out i do apologize
everybody so um back on track
uh recommendations set out in the report
are as follows uh
little one that the committee reviews
the initial update on the transformation
learning item
at appendix one and considers the date
delay for final report set out at
paragraph 3.3.3
of the report and little two
that the committee notes the initial
response and information
provided on the debt recovery process
and considers a deferment of the review
for six months
and whether it wishes to define the
screw to the item
sorry i'm on little too oh
i do apologize members uh we did have a
discussion earlier where we agreed to
scriptless
split these i believe um mrs hughes
so we're just doing little one at the
moment
apologies moving on
so that's just little one that the
committee reviews the initial update on
the transformation learning item
appendix 1 and considers the date delay
for final report set out at paragraph
3.3.3
of the report so if any member wishes to
second that motion
please um oh councillor morris
to you please
thank you council bell um can you hear
me guys
yes yeah um sorry if we can completely
skip
some of the some of the agenda because
uh i believe on page 8
um 3.4 i did uh
have you know a few things to say about
that
um i think what's happening councillor
maurice is we do the motion
and then we have the debate so we do the
motion first and then we do the
recommendation
then we do the debate am i right mrs
hughes can you
clarify that for that yes sorry i've
just presented
the first report on transformation set
out in appendix one
of um this particular report at the
moment
so then we're moving on we're not at
debt recovery yet councillor morris
that's coming up in a bit
right thank you very much thank you
welcome so i'm sorry i've got me
not just me teeth in a twist tonight
members i seem to
be a bit all over the place so i do
apologize
so um did we have a second
for that motion
councillor fleming councillor fleming
i'll second that
thank you council morris is that a
legacy hand or is that for the debate to
come
legacy and the debate to come
okay thank you um so
i will now invite members to make any
comments
on the report please so
have any members um councillor fleming
thank you chair um i just wanted to ask
cheryl a question
um cheryl would it be possible for
um the papers from that august 2018
full council meeting um when the
transformation was agreed
are they accessible on the system
they were private and confidential
documents at the time
which is why i haven't circulated them
as part of the pack
um but we can work out a way to maybe
extract the
initial information um
i have been assured by tara that they
should be accessible by the idrive but
obviously we couldn't make them part of
the public pack
because they were private and
confidential documents yes tara just
confirmed that they are accessible on
the i drive
so they are i am yeah and then cheryl
when you were um compiling your report
or when you do would you sort of refer
back to i know at the end of every
um full council or strategy resources
you have a
section on implications and you outline
impact on customers equality risk
resources
financial all the rest of it have you
reference are you referring back to
those
so those implications that you
originally identified
are you using that as the sort of point
that you go back to um
not specifically from committee reports
um the reason that customer and cost was
identified was that when we agreed the
item in january
that was um something that came out of
the committee that we um
that the committee felt that we should
be looking at um
but i could um as part of the um
further work that i do i could also
include those other criteria
thank you can i just come back yep okay
cheryl because
you know we we have all of these
committees and we
we see these laid out at the end of
every
report and i'm just interested to know
how often we do actually refer back to
them
and say you know you are you identify
those
risks and it would be quite useful i
think for this committee
to actually go and look at those and say
okay we identified them
these impacts possible impact and
you know did they come about or
yes good suggestion councillor fleming
can that be included um
cheryl please yeah i'll do some work on
that
thank you thank you thank you i mean i
have to say and i want to thank you very
much for the work you've done so far
on the report um i have to say
i am alarmed by some of it i'm
particularly alarmed by the satisfaction
survey
results and um i've looked at some other
local authorities and i know that they
are
sort of vaguely comparable to
to many what's even more alarming is the
satisfaction rates before
the their before figures which were just
woeful
to be quite honest so although it's
excellent to see that there has been
some
improvement and we are going in the
right direction
i'm still concerned at staff and
customer satisfaction levels
so i'm hoping that that's
you know something we can look at as a
result of this scrutiny item
council morley please
i was just actually looking at as well
that was funny enough as
great minds thinking that's just what i
was reading and
um wondered how things were moving
forward or if they're not or
or how's that going really with
satisfaction
and turnover of staff cheryl thank you
so so we've recently published the staff
survey results and it's gone to
performance governance and audit
committee and the good news is that
between
um 2019 and 2020 there's been
a good increase in staff satisfaction
and a decrease in staff turnover as well
um so i can share with the committee the
report that recently went to performance
governance and audit because that might
help to give a bit of
assurance
i know what it's like thank you thank
you
cheryl so do any other members wish to
um to speak on the report
i am sorry or um can we uh
vote can we go to the vote now
and can we do that by ascent members
or do we want to vote on it
can we agree that by a sense agreed
great
we'll have to go for a vote councillor
morris okay
um i think we've got a bit of a delay on
on you counselor maurice so uh apologies
i didn't get that until after we'd said
a sense so
bear with us if you try to wave at me
and i'll hopefully hang on
so that's the best way i've ever been
told that i'm slow
thank you
far be far be that from the case
councillor morris so
um tara if we could go to vote please
uh yes chairman of course members this
is voting for recommendation one
uh which is that the committee reviews
the initial update on the transformation
learning item appendix
one to the report and considers the date
delay for the final report as set out
in paragraph 3.3.3 of the report
and if you could just indicate four
against rob spain when i call your name
please
starting with councillor bassinger thank
you
four please tara thank you councillor
miss beale
paul councillor morris
abstain thank you thank you very much
chairman the results of that are six in
favor
nobody against and one abstention thank
you chairman
thank you very much tyra so that brings
us
on to the um debt recovery
process so um
cheryl do i read out the little two now
or do we have it we have a present
presentation about it yeah i can give a
bit of an intro
if you wouldn't mind that'd be helpful i
think thank you
okay so members the covering report here
outlines that this is an
initial feedback and response to the
brief given by the committee
on the matter of debt recovery process
in the document
appendix 2 found on page 19 of your pack
the officer has attempted to address the
key outcomes and bring back
an interim response the response seeks
to further provide
background information and to reassure
members that
there is an adopted corporate strategy
for debt recovery
including supporting the vulnerable
there are internal work processes in
place that reflect that strategy
there isn't a hard and fast process that
is followed and we adapt to individual
needs
and different groups of staff deal with
different stages of the debt recovery
process with more experienced staff
involved as more formal stages are
reached
it is clear that issues around
vulnerability are
difficult to assess if people do not
properly engage with the council
and provide the information that is
sought from them
staff do work closely with partner
agencies and help to support
customers that are in difficulty in may
a new government statutory initiative
will allow customers additional time
to support them with debt management but
this very much mirrors what we are
already
doing possible options for the committee
on review and consideration of this
report are
firstly if the interim report provides
the committee with sufficient level of
assurance
they could close the review if not the
committee need to be specific
in terms of what further information or
detail is required or perhaps redefine
the review
and the committee are also asked to note
that the covering report
says that if further information is
required
including for example data around
individual cases
this will at present put an unreasonable
demand on a team that are already
working under a lot of
extreme pressure and therefore that
further work
should be deferred for six months thank
you members
okay thank you very much um cheryl so
excuse me so what i will do now i'll
read out little two
and ask for a seconder and then
we will move on to debate on little two
before we vote
um but i would like to thank the
officers involved in producing the
information so far
and i would really like to acknowledge
the hard work and the pressure that
revs and ben's staff are under at the
moment
supporting the vulnerable in our
community
in these difficult times so little too
that the committee notes the initial
response and information provided on the
debt recovery process
and considers a deferment of the review
for six months
and whether it wishes to redefine the
scrutiny item
in light of the interim report at
appendix 2.
so do i have a seconder for that
if so please speak now yes
councillor mays oh counselor maize thank
you
thank you so i would like
to um and cancel them all you thank you
too so i would like
to open up the floor the virtual floor
for debate now please members
councillor morris
thank you councillor bell um i'd just
like to uh point at four um
at the the very last sentence reads
confined
to debts occurring in relation to
council tax and business rules
i would like to point out that as this
was the
my item the whole idea of bringing this
to overview and scrutiny was to make
sure
that vulnerable debtors are adequately
protected a vulnerable debtor
could have a parking ticket for instance
it should not be about
what the debt is it is all about and
solely about
who the debtor is the vulnerable people
need protection and are afforded that
protection
in law by way of the taking control of
goods act
uh sorry taking control of goods
regulations which is in the court's
tribunal enforcement regular uh
act sorry getting my accident and uh
regulations wrong
um it seems that there is
um almost a willful um
[Music]
a world
is that better guys killing me i can
hear you now yeah if you could
just repeat your last name
um it seems that there is almost um
willful commitments
to once understand this item um and i'm
very
unhappy that um as lead counsellor
and perhaps uh one of the officers can
help me with that um as i understand it
the office
that was dealing with this uh stuart
jennings is no longer with morgan
district council is that correct
no um council morris it most certainly
isn't and i've just been informed that
the corporate um
debt recovery strategy does cover
all debts not just council tax and um
and business rates so the actual
recovery strategy
that we've been presented with does
cover all
all debts right so why
say at 3.4.1 last sentence
confined to debts occurring in relation
to
was that what was it
previously cheryl could you help us out
there
we won
sorry um just where there was a break up
on uh
what sorry which point sorry um they did
we agree to limit this
to council tax and business rates at a
previous meeting
no we didn't not the recovery process
but when we defined
the request for data it was based on
okay
um that's helpful and i will i will kind
of come back councillor morris
i think that we might be helped out on
that by
by something that i'd i'd like to
propose shortly so if i can do that
after i've
heard from councillor morley and then
you come back after that is that okay
councillor morris
well can i just finish please counselor
yes go ahead
yeah um so uh we're not sure what
i mean you know the report's got holes
all over all over the place i mean 3.4.1
does say relation to council tax and
business rates quite clearly i'm
actually looking at it right now
um and now i'm told that that's
different um i'd like to know
why as lead counsellor i've uh not had
any of my emails responded to
by pretty much anyone surrounding this
whole
item and why we are dragging our feet so
badly on it
it's i've i've not spoken to stuart
jennings
once and apparently he is the lead
officer on
it i think he was given 12 weeks to do
it i'd like to know exactly how far
anyone's got because i don't think
anyone's done anything
thank you thank you councillor morris
councillor molly can i come to you
please yeah thank you chair um i'm just
saying
reading through that and then when it
got to the point where different
um people are assessed different people
looking after different needs i think
that's a really
positive way forward because people do
have
different needs and i just really wanted
to know that sharon i think i asked
before
roughly how many or what's the
percentage of
taxpayers or are in arrears
[Music]
who are struggling there's a related
disfigure on that
thank you can i interject there
sorry counselor morley and cheryl just
because i think
um if if i can just um
come in what we have here is
we have a quite some
thorough list of outputs
what we don't have is any outcomes
we have what the council is doing about
it all but we don't have
the figures on who needs us to do these
things so
i think what we need to know as
councilor morley has said
is we actually need some figures we need
some numbers
on how many people
are experiencing this process
this my understanding was this was the
information we wanted
was how people
are experiencing
these issues and what we've got is
what's the care what the council's
policy is
so my suggestion for moving forward with
this
and focus is that we actually need
those stats and i'll come to you again
now councillor morris
thanks very much councillor bell um far
too much time is being taken
over the uh eccentricities
involved in this item of scrutiny um
it's quite
simple i mean if you look at government
um information
i believe that one in three around one
in three children
in the malden district are um below the
poverty line
so we've got a lot of poor people and we
only need to
use national figures to know that that's
too many people that could be
um targeted by unreasonable uh pressure
placed on them by the authority
our local authority that are supposed to
be taking care of them
this is quite simple it's being made
very very complicated
and as i said earlier it seems that
there are people here that are committed
to misunderstanding it and muddy in the
waters
thank you thank you council morris i
mean
again i do want to um
i do want to kind of i think it's
important that we do acknowledge
the pressure that the staff are under
with the current work that they have to
do
and i think under the circumstances it
is reasonable to request
an extension but i think we haven't been
clear about the information
well have we been clear i thought we
were clear that we wanted
um we wanted out numbers because we
can't counselor morris i want a
breakdown i don't
want an overall figure i want a
breakdown so that i can know
what problems are specific
areas
[Music]
i'd like engagement from the officers
with me
i would like all of those
any any um will from this council
to take this forward i'm just seeing lip
service paid to it
sorry to interrupt you there councilor
morris um the process
is very clear and we do you have we
mr jennings stuart jennings is the lead
officer all
correspondence and communication goes
through him
that is the process that is the process
and it has to be followed and if you
feel that
mr jennings isn't responding then i will
have that conversation as chair with him
but we have to follow the process
frustrating though it is
for everyone i'll put it to everyone
don't worry about that i'll put it to
everyone
at the end of the day they haven't even
got
the the actual grasp of what we're
trying to do
correct it is not about the debt it is
about
the person who is getting the um
unreasonable um and unlawful
action taken against them
by this council i am here to hopefully
stop vulnerable people being put under
undue pressure
that they are entitled to be protected
from by law
i've done the backwards and forwards
through this quite for quite some
considerable time
i am here to to give my input as the
lead counsellor
and i don't seem to be getting anywhere
with it
and that seems to be a wanton lack of
commitment
to actually exploring this part of the
scrutiny
item thank you councillor maurice your
response is um taken on board thank you
councillor maze i think we have then
councillor miss miss beale and then
councillor fleming i think so counselor
myself to you first
uh yeah thank you um madam chairman um
i i do ask the question um you know why
hasn't there been any response to
councillor morris's um emails uh
telephone calls or whatever that is
concerning as a counsellor
um and also i thought we we had we and
we were very clear
about we we needed some basic
baseline um data and
well i can't find any baseline data here
on which to to hang all this meat you
know there's no there's no substance to
it i don't know whether we're talking
about three people
300 people 3 000 people
and what types of debts we are looking
at
and what we should be doing about it
going forward
this is it's it's good as far as it goes
but
it's not far enough and it doesn't give
us any of the information
that i am absolutely confident that we
asked for
in the first place thank you i thought
so i'm going to
councillor bill next then councillor
fleming then councillor morris
councillor bill please yeah thank you
chairman
i must admit i actually agree with
chrissy morris the uh
officer response is all not always very
good
at all and i i i i do
uh share his uh frustration with that um
in the conversations we've had up to now
it would appear to me that how can we
make a decision if we haven't got the
information we asked for
so i wasn't sure whether you were
proposing that the item was deferred
until we have all the relevant
information and then we can make an
informed decision
that is what is being proposed
councillor bill so if i can go to
councillor fleming and then back to
council morris
council fleming yes thank you chair i
was just going to make a suggestion that
perhaps
uh we could put a review
onto the agenda uh for each meeting that
we have going forward
just so that we could be sure that we're
on track
so i think as chair you can do that you
can
add that as an agenda item that you want
it reviewed
um and then also i just wanted to say
about
um councillor morris mentioned parking
fines
i think the collecting authority for
parking fines is
so thank you for that um
so um yeah i think we're all uh
counselor bill is that a legacy hand
yes sorry i'll wake up now and i think
um so i've got council morris and then
councillor bassinger so
cancer morris if you could
yourself and counselor fleming know that
even though it is uh the essex parking
partnership
the uh fundamental starting point for
the issued ticket
morton district council staff and they
passed that over
so even though there is a break in the
link as it was
uh by going over to the essex parking
partnership
um we are still initiating the
the ticket so i believe that we have a
duty of care to ensure
that any person that's issued with a
ticket should um
be um scrutinized for uh
vulnerability um i'd also just like to
bring up that um on
page sorry i'm just getting to it on
page 21 and
this is uh i'm slightly off piste but as
soon as it's here i'll bring it up
the liability order liability orders
i've given to the magistrates call on
bulk
thousands of at a time and are
simply put in front of a magistrate to
sign one of them
i will find the section of law but a
magistrate should be looking
at every single case on its own merits
and not simply
being dumped with thousands of uh
liability orders
just on the say so of a financial
officer that pays to go to the cult
and then dishes out the liability orders
the liability holders um
should be subject to scrutiny as well
that is is
also an illegal act that councils
use to actually ensure that they can get
what is seen to be an authority to send
goons around
thank you thanks councillor maurice i'm
going to go to the council
passenger now and then to cheryl
who will come back on some of the points
so council passenger please
thank you chair i would just like to ask
the question exactly
how are we defining the vulnerable and
the vulnerability i mean is that from
people that have actually
come through the council system and made
contact or are we sort of looking at
some sort of national
figures i mean how how do we know what
we're talking about
here and therein lies the problem and i
think
council morris is probably the best
place to actually help out with oh
councillor maze you have your hand up
cancel the maze
uh yeah i think i was the councillor
morris um was probably probably spotted
the same
it is actually on in part of the index
because
um i actually was concerned about that
element
uh it's on page 21 um
it does list vulnerability or it lists
some vulnerabilities and certainly
having been involved with vulnerable
people for the last
few weeks um as has councilor morris
um and and other members um
there are many that go beyond this and
and who is determining that
there are we haven't even taken
a definition from you know um
the nhs or um one of the
very um one of the other bodies that
looks at vulnerable people
you know social services etc etc um and
i am concerned that that has possibly
been overlooked
but even so um we need to know
where the definitions are coming from to
ensure they are the right ones
that somebody and that can be um
subjective so immediately if you had a
bad day
nobody's vulnerable if you have a good
day everybody's vulnerable
yeah and and that that also concerns me
uh with a system
i mean you know i'll be quantifying
vulnerability
by financial vulnerability or
mental vulnerability or poverty
i'm going to bring in councillor morris
i'm going to bring in council murray
sorry i wasn't quite sure if he'd frozen
if you
or if you had your hand up in real life
there counselor maurice so
over to you on this i think you're
probably best placed
you're frozen though
there is no legal definition of
vulnerable
and that to the nasty people's hands
because they don't have to follow any of
these uh rules
now the simple fact of the matter is
from dealing with vulnerable people
for decades and from dealing with
bailiffs for decades
but the bailiffs only get paid if they
get a result
so it doesn't suit their purpose to find
someone vulnerable
it also doesn't suit the council's
purpose to find someone vulnerable
because once
you have identified someone as
vulnerable you have to leave them alone
a little bit
otherwise they could you know ultimately
commit suicide or something else like
that
but that leaves you with the problem
and the the bailey for the problem the
counts were the problem personally
i would much rather have someone lose a
little bit of money than
have someone lose their life which is
you know
has happened on a few cases that i have
dealt with people do commit suicide
over debt worries and they do it
massively impacts people's lives
having large goons turn up
that tell you that they will keep kick
your door down even though they probably
can't
that tell you that you might we probably
won't
when they tell you that for instance
your children will be taken away from
you because you have a civil debt that
you are unable
to pay now we cannot leave the decision
on vulnerability to anyone that has a
pecuniary
interest a financial interest in it so
for instance
the officers won't be able to decide
the councillors won't be able to decide
the bailiffs definitely definitely
cannot decide because ultimately
they get paid by results so we need to
take that
that away and i would say that the
safest way to do
that that would probably be to leave the
decision of vulnerability
with medical people because those
medical
people haven't gotten
invested in getting the money they
probably have more of an interest in the
person
rather than the debt that they are
trying to collect all this
um i'm just gag in to tell
stuart jennings or anyone else that
would want to listen to
thank you and apologies you were coming
in and out there i know councillor molly
had some had his hands up but that's um
gone down again councillor bassinger
thank you i mean just to come back i
mean
i mean we're sort of stuck between a
rock and a hard place as far as i see it
because
you know we all want to protect the
vulnerable
most certainly but you know we have to
accept that there are people that are
here just to
to to bolt the system so
in a way you know the only sort of
way we have of testing this as far as i
can see i mean
clearly you know no one wants to say
that anyone is out there to buck the
system but
there are is is to use really the sort
of
the council's criterium that that's all
we have
otherwise i don't know how we how we can
decide who is vulnerable and who isn't
well i think and i'm going to disagree
with council morris because i don't
think we should leave it up to the nhs
because there are a lot of
vulnerabilities that have nothing to do
with medical
conditions so as a social worker i can
assure you of that so i think we need to
look at something and i think we
actually do need to look at
as a council drawing on the knowledge of
our partner agents
agencies and the experts and coming up
with
our own definition and getting that
approved by the people that know i think
that would be a much better way forward
council morris you're frozen councillor
maurice
thank you carl is that better guys have
you hear me
just about we can now but you're still
very coming in and very
in and out i'll try and make it quick
um councillor passenger um has a very
good point and
luckily i've already thought of that and
i've dealt with quite a few cases of
people that are robust enough for
bailiffs and that do try and pull the
vulnerability card
now if you want to look further back
into this and this was my
original suggestion we need to make
better use of an attachment of
earnings order the attachment of
earnings order can be
put on vulnerable people which would
not prevent our revenue stream from
being
collected and is a lot easier way
to um approach all debt so i'm not
saying
let the vulnerable people off i'm not
saying
let anyone off that claims to be
vulnerable because i know there's going
to be people on a swindle
what i'm trying to say is we should move
away from
goons turning up on vulnerable people's
doors and we should
replace that with the attachment of
earnings which is a relatively painless
smaller amount that goes out on a
regular basis
and that can be used to recoup the debt
i'm not asking for the debts to be wrote
off i'm asking for a different way
of that to happen an attachment of
earnings older
would be a much smarter way to approach
vulnerable debtors and that is what i'm
asking for
and i think you're pushing an open door
counselor maurice i think we all agreed
at previous meeting that that is what we
want to aim for that is what we want to
look at
but i'm i'm just not clear why we
haven't got the
the figures and the stats yet so that we
can evidence that
because yes councillor maurice you're
right we're six months however long down
the line and
we haven't got the information we need
to actually do the bit of work that we
need
so i did ask from councillor bell and
the other thing is i mean a year
ago when i first floated this idea
i was told i mean i'm a counsellor here
they told me that i had to put a freedom
of information
um requesting i am i'm a counsellor
and they asked me for a freedom of
information i've got to put a free foi
in
for my own council to try and get
there's something done
which will improve the lives of our
oh you've gone again a residence improve
the profile of
you've gone again yeah it's probably a
good thing i'm going
no i think i mean where other people
need to speak but i'm also aware that
some
time ago i did say cheryl i'd allow you
to come back on some of those points so
if i could do that
now and then go to councillor's
passenger and maze again please
cheryl yeah um i just wanted to
sort of reflect that and it is
highlighted in the header report that
you know this isn't the full report this
is an interim and
we acknowledge that it doesn't have the
detail um and the detail that you're
talking about the reason that we haven't
been able to access that is due to
service pressures
in the refs and men's team that would
need to pull it out
and it's not just the time that it would
take them to extract the data
um and give the data but is the context
set in as well
um because some um debts might have
um you know spanned different years in
terms of their recovery
and so enforcement might you know go
between different years
um and there are some long-standing
cases and they need to give that context
and
information and sort of drill down into
the data to explain it
um one thing i can say obviously knowing
the um
balanced scorecard exceptions that are
reported to the performance governance
and audit committee
is that overall our council tax
collection is down
um and that we have obviously reported
that in the medium-term financial
strategy and um
you know the budget setting for the next
year
um so obviously you know debts are up
slightly on where they would be
on that basis um
um and also just the um
the the detail that you've talked about
in terms of you know how many people are
in arrears
and what debts just to note that i've
been noting down
um that and obviously that can be fed
back
um but the report does request a
six-month extension on this on the basis
that the team that we would be asking
all of that information from
would obviously be the team that would
need to do that context setting
thank you thank you cheryl that's very
helpful i'll come to
cancer's passenger and maze in a second
but
i think we our hands are tied because
we're here
but i think we need to um i think where
where i want to go is we obviously need
this information
um so we have to give uh
staff another six months and we have to
note that um
you know no counselor maurice i can see
councilman shaking her head
he said he said sorry that you know
information hasn't been provided as
requested
but i'll come to councillor bassinger
and then council amaze and then council
morris again
thank you chair nothing really to add
i'd just like to say that you know i
fully support
council boris did you just assume
sorry
sorry i don't go ahead cancer passenger
i'm not quite sure what went on there
oh just again i just i'd say i do
support um councillor morris in this
i think that the idea of uh us using
bailiffs these days is very draconian
and archaic
and that i think his his system seems
far more likely to actually
to give us some results i think the idea
of bayless and having dealt with
bailiffs
you know there's nothing more
distressing and should somebody be
vulnerable
to actually have these people turn up at
your doorstep at your home
is is is a mugging it's rape and
i find it really distressing but
having said all those things we do need
the information
most certainly we we can't just you know
do a knee-jerk reaction
and and i feel sorry for councillor
morris because i know he wants to do
something right now as we all do
but that's not how it will possibly work
we have to let them provide the
information
and then take it forward so i'm hoping
council morris won't
go and we'll stay here because uh it's
it's
it's a good thing you're doing and i
think everybody pretty much
supports what you're doing we i can see
heads nodding for every single head
nodding here
um cancer maze did you want to come back
on that
uh yeah um i think i i absolutely
support this
um we don't have the information that is
frustrating for us that is very
frustrating
i think six months is somewhat of a long
lead-in for for that information um
and maybe we should actually be pushing
for it to be slightly shorter than that
um i i appreciate
the workloads but unless we start to get
this
information then we you know this this
is sitting and people will you know our
vulnerable people out
out on the streets are not receiving the
best that they
the service that they possibly can um so
i would like to see
that length shortened um somewhat
is that an amendment to a proposing
cancellar mars
um yes it is um i i would like
i would like to say half that length um
you know three to three to four months
at the most
thank you
thank you second did that council morris
i know you want to come back
thank you chet uh everyone's very busy i
am also very busy i go get up i get up
early and i go a bit
late and i deal with these problems not
just in the morgan district but all over
the country
um i i could spend all day
dealing with these problems
still have more at the end of it i stand
while i go
and please sympathetic with those have
got more sympathy
for the vulnerable people out there that
are um experiencing bailiffs more than
district council
are sending out bayless now um it might
be an idea that uh
maybe we stop the bailiffs going out now
on our behalf until we get this item
done and that way at least we'd know
that we're looking after our
residents um i'll put that in as an
amendment possibly
is anyone wanting to second me on
not yeah that's it not in the terms of
reference for this committee
so that would be something that would
either need to be a motion or
a suggestion to counsel um
obviously you know the normal process
with opium scrutiny is that you'd have
the full report and then
the your recommendations would be based
on the full report and your
consideration of
the full report to go to council but
this is an exceptional case
because we're having to step in and do
it to enter in measures until we've got
the information
now can we as a can we as a committee
do a motion to full council or does it
have to be one of us
i would like to put that forward as
it won't go anywhere as an amendment
councillor morris it has to be a motion
to counsel and it will just get passed
yeah emotion would go by like with one
with a member
and then with it being seconded and that
would come
notified directly and outside of the
committee
so councillors can i leave that with
um you between you to pull something
together
and propose in seconds can i leave that
i think you've support here councillor
morris so i think
um that's my motion
i'll make that emotion to the full
council down
and make that a motion for full council
it's only fair if we can't get this done
in time
we should suspend the uh negative
impacts that it might have on the
residents
that would be my concern let's put our
money where our mouths are okay
so i'll leave that um members in your
hands to put something together for
um for council i think because i think
we we have us
we have support for this so
okay did anyone else want to speak
thank you everybody for a very a very
good
debate a very good discussion really
pleased
at the um the commitment that there is
to this
and i'm even more pleased at the fact
that it's not politically
based in any way that we're actually
coming together as human beings to uh
address this issue so thank you for that
members i'm really really pleased
about that so can we move forward then
and agree with the amendment tara do you
have the
the words for that sorry i'm springing
it on you now
and pretend the recommendation was that
the committee notes the initial response
and information provided
on the debt recovery position process
sorry and considers a divert deferment
of the review
uh for six months and that's where the
change has been the
recommendation was three to four months
to redefine the scrutiny in light of the
interim report
thank you tara so um so
the amendment is to reduce that to three
to four months
and i think we've been clear on the
focus
that we want i think we've been very
clear about the focus that we want which
is um
which is the numbers but i can i can
work well we can work with officers um
but i think members clear about that
councillor bassinger then councillor
fleming
thank you madam chairman i just i just
want to sort of
just to make sure that we are clear and
you know the reporting itself i think is
fine
we just need that information to know
you know how many actual vulnerable
people how they are vulnerable
you know how they're getting in contact
it's that part of the report we're
lacking
so that i'm willing to support thank you
councillor fleming thank you chair i was
just going to suggest a date
so we're saying three to four months i
thought we could say
end of august at the latest
for the report end of august at the
latest count
thank you councillor fleming councillor
morris and then councillor morley
asking for them for that information
will be um almost pointless
uh it's like asking how long a bit of
string is um
you you can you'll never be able to
count the vulnerable people because a
lot of vulnerable people bury their head
in the sand
it isn't something that should be based
uh solely on on data like that it should
be
based on uh following uh models and
legalities the the protection is already
there for them
in law taking control of good
regulations as i keep saying
if this benefits four vulnerable people
or 400 vulnerable people
i think that the council needs to go for
it because uh we are
really missing a trick with um you know
not using attachment of earnings orders
uh more
widely than bailiffs thank you thank you
council morris and
we that we we are we do we have to have
evidence we have to provide evidence
evidence
um in order to get something to get
something through it's
it's process again that we
that we have to deal with um counselor
passenger is that a legacy hand
no madam chairman isn't i would i mean
the sort of information i would really
like to get apart from the the
vulnerable side
of it i would love to know exactly how
much money we do
recoup you know how successful are these
outside bodies because
i know they they in themselves must cost
quite a lot of money to get these people
to go and do
this and i'm not sure we actually get
the return
for the money we're paying so that is a
bit of leverage that we could use
to also strengthen our case to be honest
again i think we asked for this at the
begin back at the beginning
i'm pretty sure we did cancel the
morally sorry i think you were next
i i i said lines on similar lines to
counselor passenger
and yes it must cost an armored leg to
do it and
it doesn't sorry to interrupt council um
um the bailiffs are on uh commission
they are running on commission so anyone
that we
deem to be vulnerable they are instantly
losing money on
it doesn't cost us to um instruct the
bailiffs we
simply phone up the bailiff and we say
take this case over and then and that
that you know the the motivation
is purely financial on the bailiff's
part
is a little gold mine and if they have
to get that
gold mine alone see the thing is
vulnerable people are a lot more liable
tonight
than people that aren't vulnerable so it
actually the bailiffs actually
enjoy take
the system is completely backwards and
what we are doing here
is we are exploring an argument that is
is is
quite old which we all already have the
answers
we're never going to find out what they
understand sorry
sorry mike yeah i i totally agree
they're in business it's a private
business and i totally agree with you
but um going back onto the figures
surely it can't even take three months
to get those figures they must have it
on a
on a website somewhere on on a
are all these properties are they
privately owned that they're
being evicted from because i know your
point but some people
have bought houses and
that time please can you let cancer
molly finish please against morris
cancer molly no i was just saying
the the the evictions are they all
council properties they've been
it's not evictions morton district
council uh
as far as i'm aware don't have any
residential properties
that we would need to use bailiff before
they'd have to
better get those responses
if i had information requesting
not necessarily they quite often come
back and say that it would cost more
money than uh
is you know you know what they say
councilman
you know the excuses
i mean they could probably find out
within a couple of days the numbers
yeah you don't need three months to my
mind
if if and i was waiting for three months
for someone to make a decision i'd go
nuts
yes we do have i do appreciate this but
we do have to
remember that they have got they are
working really hard so
we've got to find a we've got to find a
solution here that is
workable because what i don't want is to
be in this situation again
in three months six months time so i'm
going to propose another amendment which
is
and also people are being oppressed you
know
by our council where they should be i
know
these members i haven't got a gavel to
bang at you
i'm going to go to the passenger next
then councillor mays
yeah i i i agree with uh with councillor
morley and councillor morris
that the figures must be at hand but i
do think we have to give them the time
but i do think we must as a committee
make it really clear on the information
that we require
and i think we need to know the
percentage that bailiffs charge
and how much of the debt we actually get
back every time they move in
which we probably won't know that we
need to know who the vulnerable people
are
or at least how many there are in some
form
in our in our district and we need to
know
how they contact the council how
how is this information councilor morris
sorry to interact
if you could finish then councillor
maize and then councillor morris
because i'm getting very confused but if
we could just really make it clear of
the exact of the information we need
and uh and and get that interesting
counts thank you councilman councillor
mays
oh yeah thank you madam chairman um
i i still stand by my original
um amendment that i made
which was seconded i think we do have to
be reasonable
i whilst i concur with some of the
comments that have been made
you know in an ideal world it would be
great if we could have it next week
um and and that that would make life
so much easier um whatever
but we are in a very tricky position we
are on this you know this road map
whether we like it or not
um let's try and be reasonable all the
way around some of our officers
themselves vulnerable yeah um
you know and and you know we we we're
throwing this word around willy nilly
and
we really shouldn't because um
you know there are people there are
people out there that do need
our support going forward and i think
ultimately
some of the recommendations that could
come from this
you know the use of an attachment of
earnings will be
perfect however we are not at that stage
at this point
and we need the information but let's be
reasonable about this
um um councillor fleming suggested the
31st of august
um that is um a a i think is a
reasonable length of time
to expect um a a decision and some
some facts and figures to come back to
this committee
to to actually scrutinize and move
forward on
thank you for allowing me to speak so
long right thank you councilman
i'm actually i want to wrap this up i i
know councilman but we are going around
in circles here and i think we've not
agreed on the fact we need this
information so i'm gonna put this to the
vote and then if it goes
if it falls
no you're frozen can you turn your
camera off and try again cancel morris
please
no you've gone
no you've done
can you hear me oh no
i'm going to take it i'm going to take
it to the vote and if the vote fails
by all means they send a letter that
cost
75 pounds and then if they visit
they charge 325 pounds
now they're charging people that haven't
got money more money
that are vulnerable so counselor
passenger thank you for your
your questions i've pretty much got it
all done now the problem that you guys
don't seem to realize
is if i put in the freedom of
information request
i am legally bound to get that
information in 30 days
except we are going to say oh tell you
what
let's let's actually give them more time
than what they would legally
be required if the member of the public
put this in
this is ridiculous yes we are going to
do
that because i suggest if you did and by
all means council members do put in a
freedom
of information request because i'd be
interested to see if you do get that
back within 30 days
or if you get the response which says we
are unable to provide this information
in this within this time period
because of blah blah blah blah so i
think we're doing
double-edged you know two-pronged attack
this has been months and we are not
getting
stuff done that will benefit our
vulnerable residents
30 days is the time limit that they
should be
held to and at the time limit they would
be held to by a member of the public
we are counsellors we should be
requesting
at least what the residents have we
should be entitled to get this
information
a little bit quicker than most residents
because we are making
important decisions they are mugging us
off okay then can i suggest council
maurice that you propose an
amendment that we have the information
within 30 days that we vote on that
and then if that falls i think the
correct procedure is we then go to
councillor rum mazes amendment
i'm not sure whether we need to
differentiate between 35 30th of august
in three months so
i think i'd be happy to take uh
councillor morris's motion first
if it has a seconder so do i have a
second
for councillor morris's amendment which
i believe
is to change the period from six months
to
30 days do we have a seconder for that
amendment
counselor maurice we don't i'm afraid oh
councillor fleming are you second doing
that
oh my god you're not agreeing
can we let cancer do this if i
thank you councillor morris cancer
fleming chair i was just going to say
that the
the difference um councillor morris is
requesting information but i think the
officers are asking
for till you know well they were asking
for six months to write a report which
is a larger piece of work
so i just didn't want the two mixed up
so yeah so i i think that councilor
morris should
should do his freedom of information
request for the
information i think we should allow the
officers
until the end of august to do the report
which is a bigger piece of work
and then we can go go from there at the
end of august
so do we have a second for councillor
maurice's um end of august because
that's longer that's four months isn't
it
that's the maze yeah could i could i
come in um
we we need to really vote on my
amendment
uh which was an amendment to the
original um
uh uh
yes you're right nobody seconded
councillor fleming's amendment did they
and councillor morris's amendment
being the most recent one needed to be
heard first i believe that is procedure
so then we would go to your amendment of
the three months
which uh was seconded i believe by
council field mobile councillor bill
so if we can now you know i could then
interrupt you madam chairman
um councillor fleming then asked for it
to
to to be a date i agreed with that
another amendment sorry to cut you
council mates
so i suppose if that was now proposed
that would be the most recent
amendment and then we would have to take
that before we took council of maize's
amendments so
councillor fleming do you wish to make
that amendment
and if so do we have a second or for
that amendment
thank you chair now i was just
suggesting a date just because it's
it's i think we said three or four
months i just think putting a date on it
is
is a bit more solid that's all you know
okay so
thank you councillor maze you could
amend your amendment of the original
recommendation and say
okay i would like to make an amendment
that it is
the 31st of august which actually as
you're quite rightly saying is actually
i think
four months um and a little bit
um for from today um
so so it would then go to a uh meeting
that would be sometime in october uh
september
um thank you do i have a second
for that or is counselor beale prepared
to second that
as a date councillor fleming second that
thank you okay september does feel like
an awful long time away doesn't it
really but but then i think we have a
summer recess
do we have a summer recess i don't know
that was wishful thinking members wasn't
it there so
um okay so we have the
amendment to the amendment which is that
we have the information by the
31st of august so um
tara can we take a vote on that madam
chairman could we just
check yes could we just check with
could we just check with mrs hughes that
that amendment
to the amendment is is has been done
correctly
i think it's tara that will help us out
with that i beg your pardon could this
bird tell us
yes chairman i'm happy that we followed
the right procedure in respect to that
yes
thank you very much sarah for that
so now i believe we do go to the
the um vote on the amendment which is
so this recommendation now reads
chairman
sorry the committee notes the initial
response and information provided
on the debt recovery process and agrees
a deferment of the review to the 31st of
august 2021
and then it says whether it wishes to
refine redefine the scrutiny items
in light of the interim report thank you
i think we've agreed that we do want to
redefine the scrutiny
items and i do think we've been clear on
those but
can i just bring cheryl in please to
confirm that
yeah so i've captured all the specific
data requests that have been made in the
meeting and i will pass them on to mr
jennings
thank you very much for that okay so can
we have a river
pardon council maurice any chance you
can get stuart to ring me
like i haven't already asked him
yes councillor morris i will ensure that
that is passed on
so if we can i believe um
well it will be a recorded vote won't it
i think anyway so um i'm proposing a
recorded vote i'm sure council morris is
seconding that if
uh so if we yeah
so uh if we can vote on the
motion that the committee notes that the
initial response and information
provided on the debt recovery process
and considers a deferment of the review
until the
31st of august and that we do
wish to redefine the scrutiny item um
in the manner already discussed
so if i could ask tara to call the vote
on that please
thank you chairman members if you could
just indicate if you're fought against
or abstaining uh when i kill your name
please
starting with councillor bassinger four
thank you councilman
before reluctantly i would have liked to
have seen it done a lot quicker but
i have to go with general consensus i'm
afraid
thank you council bell for please
council mrs fleming four
thank you thank you casa mays
four thank you can you cancel morley
it appears to have frozen
[Music]
thank you very much so chairman the
results of that are
six in favor one against and no
abstentions thank you very much
thank you very much sarah and thank you
members
so um that brings us onto item number
nine
any other items of business that the
chairman decides are urgent now
members we do have to produce an
annual report so uh
i don't know if um members have anything
that they wish to feed into that but if
they could
do that via me please
um via email and um
i will be working with stuart jennings
on
on that report well stuart will be doing
the work and i will be
supporting council morris
yeah could we put the uh annual report
back for six months please
because we're all really busy you know
so let's put it all back for six months
say
this is something that i'm told we do
i've really
you know it's it's something that is
done again it's a procedural thing
so uh if we could do that
please if we could make sure that i had
any if i
if we could make sure that um any
information you'd like
comes forward so in the report comes to
me or director stewart that would be
great
thank you very much forward but i'm
gonna delay it by six months
just because i can because you guys will
let it happen
i'm not sure that you can actually um
cheryl it's it's a thing isn't it you
can't make me give
six months oh we've got a thing but they
ain't got a thing that's a thing isn't
it
so you clarify sheryl please so an
annual report
of the activity of the committee um is
just an expected part of the process um
that would then be reported back to
council so the council can see
what the committee's been up to over the
last year
thank you so yeah out of ours
to get their finger out the committee's
been waiting on the officers to get
their fingers out that's what they've
been doing
i'm sure we can uh add that uh
submission to the report
councilor maurice so uh that brings us
on to item
10 which is closure of the meeting
members thank you for your contributions
this afternoon thank you very much it
has been lively
and uh and frustrating i acknowledge
that
so uh thank you for bearing with us and
i now draw the meeting to a close
at 7 21 pm
so as the meeting is now closed members
please you're advised not to enter into
any
further discussion on this forum and to
please leave the meeting promptly
thank you thank you thank you